hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game I was played in round 4
of the 2019 US Championship it's a
formal Rogers championship challenger
Fabiana Caruana versus linear Dominguez
Paris it's a really really an impressive
game it's very complicated game I'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it and it has a lot
of interesting turn of turn of events
which you'll see and we're also gonna
discuss the title a little bit after you
check out the game so let's see it
Korona drew his previous three games so
now he has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 now without further ado with
Knight to f6 by Dominguez we saw the
Indian game for now c4 e6 and here not
Khurana isn't interested maybe in asking
for for an Enzo so he goes g3 the
Catalan opening we have d5 by Dominguez
Bishop to g2 Bishop to e7 preparing
Castle Knight to f3 both players Castle
and now D captures on c4 and this is the
the standard line of the Catalan opening
Queen to a4 going after the DC for pawn
and the black of course will just allow
white to capture it while expanding his
queen size phone structure we have b5
Queen to c2 and now Bishop to b7 so it's
a very nice position for both white and
black Bishop to D to developing and
Bishop to e4 now kicking the Queen
further back Queen to see one and only
now c6 a nice solid pawn structure and
now the bishop is not closed on b7 we
have a four by white immediately
challenging this point for advancement
black cradle on the Queen side 9b d7 and
now Knight to c3 attacking the bishop
and now the bishop switches sides butter
up to g6 so instead of keeping it on
this diagonal now black has a very nice
Bishop although on this diagonal with
Knight to h4 challenging blacks bishop
on g6 and Bishop to h5 and here the
position has been reached many times in
very strong players games a captor son
b5 is a non move in this position also
look to e one is a non move in this
position but here we have h3 and it's a
new
move and already now from 15 we have a
completely new game so Caruana
definitely came prepared for this game
we have Knight to d5 by black offering a
trade nice but also opening up a
discovery here against this night and
here first a capture Sun b5 now black
doesn't have the chance to immediately
capture here on h4 because you get B
captures on c6 y just grabs another pawn
and he will of course grab yet another
piece
so once you've moved the bishop
lightsaber six or a seven you will
capture the nice Queen captures and the
white will just be up upon and black
didn't really ruin any any porn
structures on the King side so after a
capture some b5 we have a capture some
b5 route captures Queen captures and now
efore attacking the knight here you
don't want to capture here you're just
gonna really improve White's pawn
structure so here we have nice to be
four and now Bishop to g5 finally
preventing this bishop from capturing on
h4 and Queen to d8 defending the bishop
on e7 Bishop capture screen captures and
now quaint III just you know putting
putting the Queen on a nice central
square and rook to d8 by black karana
develops the rook and C 1 as the Queen
made the room for rockin c1 nice to f8
and the now comes Bishop to f3 offering
your trade of bishops and Bishop
captures Knight captures and nice to d7
so here pretty there are pretty nice
position the material is completely
equal both players with to pawn islands
and well Kappa Blancas sorry Cara
Juana's structure in front of the King
not as good as the one in front of
Dominguez
King but ok King to g2 by Caruana and
now you might think think about going
something like e 5 I mean if white if
white allows it why not just push it but
then white can get a very strong past D
pawn in the center so black black is not
interested in doing this and so here
black plays age six he has to ruin his
pawn structure a bit but at least you
will take away some important squares
from White's pieces
h4 by Caruana and the now Knight the
beasts
preparing to jump to c4 to attack the
Queen and the b2 pawn
we have b3 now karana takes away da 4 NC
4 squares from a Dominguez night night
back to d7 and now comes Luke to d1 now
karana is interested in Reema nuvaring
the night's end the rook will be useful
here giving further protection to the d4
pawn we have looked a 8 perhaps with
ideas of nice way to good ideas of
exchanging knights and then maybe the
route can infiltrate the whites position
so first Queen to e2 not allowing it we
had tonight back to f6 and now night
Stewie 5 so an excellent square for the
knight
the knight is now stuck on b4 for the
moment as the knight is also pressuring
the c6 pawn with Knight to d7 hoping to
trade off at least one pair of nice but
karana isn't interested Knight to g4
with Knight to f6 again Dominguez tries
to trade off a pair of Knights Knights
the e3 getting out of the way and now
comes Luke to a3 going after the b3 pawn
and here Khurana
yeah just offers it you could go Queen B
- Dan rook goes back and then we just
repeat moves but here karana has an
active plan he goes he five will Knight
to d7 and now comes nice the e4 so
karana offers the b3 pawn in exchange to
go for foreign attack so here if you
capture then looked a one will be very
strong threatening the rook to
infiltrate Black's Queen side and after
you go and I'd be six defending at the
knight to c5 and the White will get a
lot of a lot of activity for the price
of one pawn so here after Knights the e4
we have nice to b6 immediately now
defending the DA 8 square and also the
knight can now come to d5 but here Queen
to h5 Caruana again offers the pawn and
here Domingues characters that we look
after son b3 and now nice to g4 so you
can see already that karana just puts
the the pieces in front of the black
King a lot of nice attacking potential
here we have night 4th to d5 you do have
to keep an eye on the f6 square and here
rook to a
one is played and now the best idea for
black here would have been rooked to d3
just a nice active move for a square for
the rook you're pressuring the d4 pawn
but here black played a different idea
black played rook to a3 and now you can
see the problem here the rook is
protected by the Queen the queen is on
e7 but the queen is somehow too busy
guarding the rook on a3 and also keeping
an eye on the f6 square so how do you
how do you continue with the white
pieces here feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the correct way to
continue here I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it you are an excellent
attacker of the King side and for a Jew
who just want to enjoy the show in the
game karana played Knight captures on h6
but it seems that night eat f6 was an
even better idea because now if you
capture with the Jeep on then the game
is just over Knight captures on h6 check
King has to move now comes rogue
captures on a3 and well either the Queen
will capture and then you will get to
this check King captures and Queen to g5
checkmate or if you don't after this
night - after this Knight to f6 check if
you play Knight captures on f6 then you
get a captures on f6 and again your
queen is under attack and your look is
still under attack so you will have to
grab the pawn G captors on f6 and now
comes Knight captures on f6 with check
again you can either capture and then
allow row captures where white would be
up the exchange or you could go King to
g7 but now Queen to e5 will be will be
so deadly again you are threatening all
sorts of discoveries
you are still pressuring the rook and
there's not much all you can do here you
can either capture where after a couple
of exchanges white will be up the
exchange or instead after the screen -
if I move you could go for row captures
and a one but then we have a very nice
forcing checkmate sequence in 398 check
a double check from the Queen and the
night if King to f8 then Queen to h8
will be checkmate so you'll have to go
King g6 h5 check King - h7
now Queen to g7 this will be checkmate
so there's that and also after this rook
to a3 qur'anic lady Knight captures on
h6 so here we have pawn captures on h6
and only now Knight to f6 checked Knight
captures he captures on f6 and here if
you continue let's say Queen to a fate
where you want to keep an eye on the h6
pawn but also on the rook you don't
capture the rook first because then
after you capture on h6 the Queen can
just return to f8 and you defend
checkmate what you want to do is Queen
g4 check and only after the King moves
now you capture and now the Queen can no
longer capture because Queen to g7 again
will be checkmate so here Dominguez
found a nice way that he will give up
the exchange but in a way that he
himself refers Luke captures on g3 with
check we have F captors and g3 and only
now Queen captures on f6 so at least now
yes he's done the exchange but he's up
two points at least you know better than
nothing
Queen to g4 check by Caruana King h8 and
now rook to a6 attacking the knight here
and Queen to d8 you don't want to move
the knight and lose the c6 pawn rook to
e7 going after the f7 pawn we have Queen
to f8 and now Queen to f3 pressuring the
f7 pawn Dominguez defense at King to g8
and now Queen captures on c6 as it was a
double attack against the f7 and c6 pawn
we have Queen to d8 defending the knight
and here a very interesting position
where karana played came to H 2 but
there was a much better idea here seems
both of them missed it
Queen to f3 should win the game for
white because you're again threatening
Queen captures on f7 which would follow
up with checkmate and after black
defends it let's say Queen to a fate now
you get Queen to be 7 and now black can
no longer defend you cannot defend Queen
captures here if Queen defends night
then Queen captures on f7 is a threat
and lastly but not leastly after 95
rotate wins the Queen so the Queen to f3
a very powerful idea for white here
but Khurana went into h2 and now comes
Queen to f6 black manages to activate
the Queen now because well of course if
you capture the night Queen captures and
b6r then it's just going to have to
check and white will not be able white
will not be able to get out of all of
the checks because if you try and escape
King g4 then of course Quinta 5 will be
checkmate and you don't want to end the
game like this
so after Queen to f6 we have Queen to e4
by white the knight cannot be captured
Khurana missed this and now comes the
Queen to f2 check black will now force
right to defend King to h3 we have Queen
to f1 check Queen to g2 and now Queen to
f5 check g4 blocking Queen to d3 check
Queen to g3 and now Queen captures on d4
so for this well slight blunder karana
now had to offer yet another pawn we
have g5 by Caruana h5 black of course
wants to close the position but now even
g6 Corona wants to now open up the
position we have Knight to d7 an
excellent defensive move that I'm sure
was not easy to find as both the rook
and Queen and the pawn are all eyeing
that black king so here rook to e8 e
check was played King to g7 and now pawn
captures opening up by discovery from
the Queen King captures now comes Queen
to G a check King to e7 and not rook to
e8 check going after the e6 pawn king d6
rook captures on e6 kink the c5 and
Queen to g5 check we have King Tubby for
and it's so amazing that black is still
surviving this that Dominguez King is
just going going on across the entire
board Queen captures on h5 it's
important to get rid of this pawn now
you will position your pieces very
nicely and you will start pushing your H
bone as well
we have Knights to c5 by black rook to
e7 and then out comes Knight to d3 and
here Queen to f3 threatening rook to e4
which would win you the Queen
so kink the c3 black gets the King out
of the way and white starts pushing H
but the black also starts pushing we
have b4 h6 b 3 we have h 7 point 2 B 2
and now comes look - b7 just preventing
black from queening we have kink 2 D 2
now preparing to play king c1 and try to
promote the pawn that way
Queen to g2 check King to c1 and now
rook the c7 check kink the b1 and now
Queen the h1 check we have nice to see
one blocking check and here again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best how do you continue this you
have to win the game of course and the
position is winning for white but how do
you do it I'll give you a couple of
seconds try to figure out it's a really
complicated position so you know if you
can try and get as much time into it as
possible so for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations you are
this can even be called a study so you
are definitely an excellent solver of
studies and for those who just want to
enjoy it show the move you have to play
is rook to f7 this is the idea after
rook to f7 you will be able to prevent
any incoming checks with Queen to f3 and
then when you have both the rook and the
Queen on the F file controlling any
checks black might deliver then you will
play rook to f8 control the the last
rank control H it and then you will
promote the pawn this is the correct and
the correct path to victory here karana
played Quinta a 8 are controlling the h8
square immediately with the Queen but
now it simply doesn't work here
Domingues played Queen to e3 and now we
enter a long series of checks we have
King to g4 Queen the e6 check now King
to f3 but now Quinta e to check the
knight allows the Queen to check from
here King g3 we have Queen to e5 check
King to h3 and now not capturing the
rook this would be very advantageous for
white as then white would be able to
Queen but Queen to h5 check King g2 now
comes Queen e2 check King - h1 and Queen
to h5 check now white controls this very
nice diagonal from where the black Queen
will deliver checks we have King to g1
Queen to d1 check
King 2h2 now comes Queen to h5 check
King g3 Queen to e5 check now came to g4
and Queen to b6 check quick king to h5
Queen to f5 check King to h4 now Queen
to f4 check and now you will not be able
to deliver any more checks Queen to h4
King to h5 Queen to a5 King page 4 end
after Queen to f4 it was in this
position that Fabiana corona and Lanier
Dominguez Paris agreed to a draw so game
4 in the u.s. championship 2019 ends
with yet another draw for Fabiano
Caruana
and if things weren't as bad as they are
missing so many winning opportunities
this game Magnus Carlsen additionally
you know well we could say that he
trolled him on Twitter saying that
Coronas not winning streak in passes his
age so corona now has drawn more games
or he hasn't won more games then then he
has years of age which you know after
missing so many opportunities in one
game when you see that it can be well it
can be somewhat salty I would say but
yeah that's what happens in the chess
world you know it's it's always hard so
I do hope you enjoyed this game Caruana
most likely didn't but it was a
complicated game especially that moment
where were domingus really tricked him
where corona was offered a knight and of
course he couldn't capture the knight
but it just you know it just wasn't his
day but yeah yet another game Caruana
did not win and you know it continues
the round 5 is now being played so if
any interesting game arises I'll be sure
to show it I would like to thank Mario
and Somoza and of course I will put a
link to Magnus is tweet if you want to
check it out it will be the first thing
you will see in the description below so
feel free to check it out and yeah as
usual you can check to my previous
videos your think all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content I think you'll
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday
[Music]